let's do the shahada first and then
we'll ask him about his journey and
stuff are you down for that one
all right so let's get the most
important thing out of the way so I'm
gonna share my screen just like I did
for the our last brother that accepted
Islam can you guys see my screen uh yeah
yes okay firstly Ronnie I want to ask
just to make sure that you have your
your beliefs islamically in line before
we do the shahada do you believe that
there's only one God worthy of worship
and he has no Partners or Associates yes
perfect do you believe in the Angels
yeah do you believe in the prophets and
Messengers that God sent yes do you
believe in the Revelation that God has
sent with these prophets like the Torah
like the gospel like the Quran yes
perfect do you believe in destiny that
God has for all of us a Divine decree
that he has yes and lastly do you
believe in the day of judgment yes
perfect so now all you're going to do is
repeat after me let's bring the um the
shahada back on the screen yes so you're
gonna repeat after me in Arabic and then
you're gonna gonna repeat after me in
English Okay you ready
okay and
Allah
and now you're going to repeat after me
in English I bear witness I bear witness
that there is none worthy of worship
except Allah that there is none worthy
of worship except Allah and I bear
witness and I bear witness that the
prophet Muhammad that the prophet
Muhammad is the final messenger of God
is defined a messenger of them and the
final prophet of God and the final
prophet of that
welcome to Islam our brother Ronnie your
name is
[Laughter]
we want to know about your story man
yeah tell us a bit about your journey
and where you were introduced
well
I would say it all started like maybe
like two years ago
when I got I got really sick
I got a stomach a stomach illness which
I still have today which we don't really
we don't know what it is pretty much wow
yeah and you know like
I would say like that that like pushed
me into like a depression really and I
kind of started um
I went towards like you know substance
abuse smoking weed a lot I look young
but I'm 20.
so so I was doing that a lot and then I
would say about like
three months ago I started just like
looking more into religion
and you know I'm actually a born
Catholic but like it was never like it
was never pushed upon me or my family or
like my brothers or sisters
it was never pushed on us
so when I started doing my research I I
was really open-minded I didn't really
know anything about any religion
and to me Islam just automatically
instantly just made the most just in the
sense to me I guess you could say
yeah and like I had a lot of trouble
stop stopping like I could I I would
smoke a lot really and
and it was hard for me to stop him but
once I accepted the like like I was once
I realized that Islam is the truth I'm I
went cold turkey like it was nothing wow
wow that is bad how long have you been
feeling that way bro that Islam is the
truth
um I would say it was probably about a
month and a half ago when I when I
really really realized that and even
when that happened you know because of
like my stomach sickness it's really
hard for me to get a job like a normal
job because
I I just struggle with a lot of like
pains and and I'm stuck in the restroom
and that's a whole lot of stuff and whoa
whoa whoa whoa hold up hold up bro
are you are you gluten intolerant or
lactose intolerant no
how do you know
uh I I've gotten a lot of tests done
look I'll let everyone just kind of like
be their own test subjects and see for
themselves when they try it out
I do that
um diet actually like a lot of meat and
fruit really meat yeah
yeah it's it's I'm I'm I'm not like
super super strict about it but I have
like a few steaks a day for the most
part I drink raw milk another thing you
said about lactose intolerance is a lot
of the time you're intolerant to like
the fake crab milk with a bunch of
hormones and stuff in it and not like
actually raw milk and like I my health
guy um I have like a personal health
coach and he said there's been tons of
lactose intolerant people who then
switch to you know raw organic milk
which you can't even get at stores you
have to order it as like pet food
because it's not like supposed to be
drank it's all part of the Matrix scam
but then they're totally fine when
you're drinking like just natural milk
not with a bunch of chemicals and stuff
it's crazy
I gotta try some of this I I don't want
to talk too much because I know this is
a special moment but I went through I
went through something too like that not
with my stomach but with my skin and the
thing was cutting out GMO foods and a
lot of Highly processed stuff that was
the biggest thing for me and making sure
I switched to like a more meat based
diet and more organic food
um completely changed it they they
couldn't even like I had my whole skin
was red from head to toe I I couldn't
sleep I was so itchy it was horrible and
no doctor knew what it was and in a
matter of days of switching to healthier
food I was all good that's all I got to
say though I don't wanna
ramble someone suggested Ronnie pick up
the book medical medium
but Ronnie bro I got some questions for
you if Anna's done with all the medical
diagnosis stuff uh which I'm done to
pick that up later too
um but on your journey bro did you have
any doubts when you kind of realized
that you know what Islam is the truth a
lot of brothers and sisters they have
they have some doubts with family
you know other brothers and sisters they
have doubts with themselves or it could
be even with desires bro because a lot
of them are like you know what I really
want to smoke this one thing or drink
this one thing or go to this one place
but now I can no longer do that as a
Muslim so they would rather basically
confuse themselves into delusion into
that Islam is not real instead of just
accept that maybe I can't do this one
thing anymore
I feel they're what you're talking about
how they want to do certain things I'm
always someone who wanted uh my whole
left arm tattooed
and and stuff like that but like I think
I never had really doubts like that
because once I like really started
looking into it and just seeing like you
know one of the biggest things for me is
how how in Islam they tell you to seek
knowledge and seek everything
and so to me that's like it it's just
amazing and it just like really opened
my eyes so now like I couldn't care less
about these things at all like
well it's I don't know no that's
beautifully said actually that kind of
um
that kind of um touches on one question
I have for you which is I think Sunny is
going down a very similar path where he
is looking for the truth and he's
looking for what is true and there's
actually one comment earlier about this
do you have any advice or any general
thought since you've been down this path
already
um like advice on what like like seeking
the truth
um and uh maybe maybe from an assigned
perspective maybe not it's completely up
to you because it's your journey but uh
advice on going down this path and
looking for the truth from God
I mean I would say just like I've heard
a lot of people say this but like really
just I feel like I'm thankful like I was
born Catholic but you know it was like
I've never really been religious it was
never pushed on me so I was very
unbiased
and to support to me there was I've
always like believed in there was a God
and that and that was like the extent so
like I just like the Islam just called
me the most because you know the one God
everything the Christianity to me always
was like a little
a little far out there with the Trinity
and especially Catholicism with like the
donations and everything
so yeah I would say just look at it from
an unbiased perspective really and just
don't yeah that's pretty much it
honestly I really don't know the baskets
they bring around
two percent of you are about to say bro
I was just about to say I remember that
I used to shove that basket down your
throat no no I don't have
for you bro that's that's funny Ronnie
where are you from by the way uh I mean
I'm originally from Los Angeles and uh
now so like California now I live in
Washington state I moved here about
like three four years ago now oh nice
yeah so you know the West not not the
greatest place
I wanted to move California initially
until I got older and realized how left
it is I didn't want to leave and once I
left and I never want to go back never
yeah screw that dude
all right guys uh do you any of you guys
around me I know or even Sunny bro Sonny
do you have any questions for Ronnie
anything else that you know because I'm
sure you know he was exactly where you
might be not too long ago in his journey
yeah so um where did you like kind of
find Islam like I was it through more of
YouTube or do you have Muslim
um friends I have I don't I know one
Muslim and he's like a pretty
like I don't want to say but he's not a
great representation of being a Muslim
so yeah I would say I really just found
it through like just like I I was just
curious in religion in general so I kind
of just started learning about all the
religions and Islam just to me drew the
most and you know videos for sure like
is where I really learned the most you
know I've actually seen your your videos
with your mom react which I like because
you know your mom reminds you of my mom
a lot actually
so I wrote like yeah just videos and
just learning about all different types
of religions and seeing what called me
huh that's awesome man
wow
um I can't really think of any other
questions if you guys don't mind yeah
yeah yeah I just like um
you guys you had a podcast and we're
talking uh I think his name was Gabriel
and but uh if I had mentioned that when
you seek knowledge you should seek it in
the right places and I just wanted to
know like what you think are like the
right places to to seek this knowledge
and the wrong places
around me please
yeah so first and foremost the best
place would be the um the Quran do you
have a copy by the way no I was actually
gonna ask about that too because there's
so many different translations for the
English like I just don't know which one
okay so we're gonna make a we're gonna
make an Instagram group chat bro as soon
as we're done like we did with brother
Sheed who took a shot of the last week
and we'll send you a couple resources
there just that we do with some of the
other brothers and sisters such as um
you know resources on how to pray and
basics of that and in that if you want
you can send us your address and we'd
love to send you one
of course of course you're our brother
man you're our brother in Islam
alhamdulillah so any other questions
uh I actually like wrote like two or
three down real quick let me see let's
go for it
oh yeah so one question I had is about
the fast and so you know for someone
like me like I am sick so like I I I
can't really gain weight in general
like I actually lost like 30 pounds in
two weeks when I first got sick and so
like it like I feel like it's kind of
dangerous for me not to eat sometimes
yeah
that's a great question so islamically
um every rule every general rule has its
exceptions right
um and this is a great exception of it
if a person the scholarship if a
person's health is at risk or they could
die as a result of fasting then that
person is not obligated to Fast Very
similarly when you look at we've
discussed this earlier you know pork is
Haram to eat but at the same time if
you're dying and there's nothing to eat
except pork then now it's actually an
obligation for you to eat that pork to
continue to survive
so likewise this is an exception when a
you know perhaps a woman who's pregnant
she and the baby might be at stake um or
someone in your case they might be at
stake some the scholars say that in in
some of these cases the person's not
obligated to fast
and yo if you didn't mind I actually
wanted to read a Quran verse bro that
goes into that very in depth and it's in
a chapter two Surah al-baqarah in verse
183 so it says o Believers fasting is
prescribed for you as it was for those
before you so perhaps you will become
mindful of God and then the 184th verse
Allah says fast a prescribed number of
days but whoever of you is ill or on a
journey then let them fast an equal
number of days after Ramadan but for
those who can only fast with extreme
difficulty compensation can be made by
feeding a needy person
for every day that is not fasted but
whoever volunteers to give more is
better for them and then this needy
person in the sub note basically says
this in in the case of old age or
chronic disease so in your case
so I should like put it forward and try
to feed someone in need pretty much yeah
you could do that or we can we can hit
up some people of knowledge in our
Circle that might you know be able to
answer that a little bit more
professionally
oh and then another question I had like
you know I I really want to try halami
you know I I really want to want to eat
it but like how do I go about finding a
place around like me that South salami
head out of meat it's gonna put me on
Google bro if you put Google just on
Google uh Halal Supermarket
near me and you should be able to find a
place like bro I was looking for a place
when my mom had moved out to where she
lives now I can't say obviously you
can't believe my location like this but
I didn't I didn't know there was one
like right here next to me like
literally less than two minutes away
from me wow yeah so you'll never know
until you put it on Google and find out
hmm
yeah you could also go to a mosque uh
there's a lot of Muslims there they will
know the in and outs they'll know the
best uh places inshallah to get for it
all right so floor is still open to you
and sunny if either of you guys have
questions and also I guess to the
comments as well if you guys if the
viewers have questions
inshallah so I'll just put up the super
chats but in the meantime uh just a
quick reminder to Sunny take your time
bro until the next stream do a little
bit more research and your mom is
welcome to do so herself like we talked
about in the previous stream and to all
the viewers guys stay tuned for March
2023 one of the biggest guests if not
the biggest guest that we've had so far
this is going to be a really hype
in-person podcast we're going somewhere
overseas I'll leave it at that
Insha'Allah but here's the first Super
Chat AWS writes I always love listening
to these conversations much respect to
this channel for all the knowledge it's
spreading lots of love and respect from
Kuwait may Allah bless you and accept it
from us
as you have a question for you Ronnie
why did you want to get a full sleeve
tattoo
you know I really and that's another
thing I really don't even know it was
just like something I wanted
I was always like you know you see it
and like thankfully I I mean I think I I
have one small but I'm but like I was I
had like plans to get the whole thing
like really soon and then like I'm glad
I did I really did it now honestly yeah
bro
um
Aesthetics really yeah yeah so altering
altering the uh creation of Allah so
tattoo in essence you're altering the
creation
but also depends on what you're doing to
alter so if you're trying to restore the
creation of Allah such as you know
basically some types of surgery on the
body that basically does alter it but it
kind of brings it back to what it should
be Prosthetics and stuff like that it's
obviously a different case than let's
say for a sister that just wants a
bigger behind that's not permissible
yeah yeah for sure that's crazy man
I used to think the same thing about
that
what's up bro oh no like earlier I was
saying um you know it was hard for me to
get a job but
literally like I accepted Islam like
that thought was the truth
and like crazy like I got like probably
the best job opportunity I could have
ever got like two weeks ago or like a
week ago wow sometimes yeah and it was
just like I was like it's like amazing
to me or something it was beautiful
that is beautiful
100 uh Sunny do you have any questions
for us my man
um I have a few more but I have to run
soon my mom is begging me to to film
some videos last time but you should
just give us one last question bro one
last question
yes please what all right because I
don't want to go down a whole rabbit
hole with um you know the 7-Eleven one
um what's the what's the line between
standing up for what you believe in and
fighting hate with love so I think we
kind of touched upon this last time
where Tate's and I'm sorry to bring up
Tate a lot but
um one of the big things he said was
like how Christian Christians will say
or allow people to say God is gay you
know Jesus is gay and they won't do
anything about it but Muslims
um that wouldn't slide so what's the
difference if someone's saying something
like that
um like do you like do you go after that
with love and to try to teach them
um because the way he kind of said it
was like there's serious repercussions
from that from Muslims
you kind of understand what I'm saying
yeah 100 so this is a very interesting
topic because a lot of people talk about
it like being a positive note for
Muslims
um you will always have the Muslims that
you know turn to violence and to do um
certain things and certain actions
um other times Allah God himself would
just do with these people like the guy
um I forget where he was he might be in
Denmark he was a he was burning the
Quran and all this stuff and then his
car just happened to Tumble over killing
him and the bodyguards that are with him
um Islam doesn't especially like we're
living in a non-muslim country in these
these lands Islam doesn't allow us to
actually go and retaliate against
someone unless they're physically
attacking us you know then then we can
defend ourselves and fight them back and
so on and so forth but usually for these
people we we don't always respond with
love I think that's a very Christian
thing in some cases we will depending on
the person but we respond with what is
reasonable so if someone is for example
going in the streets and saying
something like oh all Muslims are are
teas and they do extreme things and all
this stuff then we can humiliate them by
saying what about your own country what
about you know America when they there's
currently still you know doing things in
places like Syria and other places what
about you guys why are you guys actually
you've caused the most destruction the
most innocent lives lost and we can
humiliate them publicly so they um don't
speak on Islam again
interesting
yeah that makes sense going at it with
the logical point of view rather than
just hugs and kisses Non-Stop
yeah Romy why don't you tell them what
happens if someone in the society
actually does start saying something
like
if they were gay or something like this
because I think this is like this is no
this is this is something that like many
people have a misconception on and they
think that oh just because someone comes
out as this or whatever they're going to
be basically lashed to death or
something why don't you explain exactly
how like the process goes so you can
kind of you know bring some clarity into
this picture and yo just a reminder we
should mind the specific terms that we
say bro because we're on YouTube yeah
yeah yeah yeah
course
um well are you talking about like an
Islamic Society or in this Society
and Okay so
in Islam we had this thing known as
Sharia
right
speak about what happens with that
well I mean islamically speaking Sharia
doesn't differentiate a gay person from
a straight person that's something only
the West does or you are homosexual you
are heterosexual you are a lesbian you
are trans you are this you are that you
identify as a freaking wolf standard and
uh doesn't have anything like that
um you know Islam has we have men we
have women and uh men will have certain
obligations that women won't like uh you
know earning providing for the family
going to war and all that stuff and
there's a differentiation there but
there's no differentiation between a gay
person a straight person
um it is Haram to act upon those desires
you know if you if you are a gay person
and you
um you know do sleep with another man
that is something that's Haram but it's
very difficult for a punishment to
actually be enacted because for
something like that to happen
we would have to have four male
witnesses that actually see the pen go
on the ink and all this stuff that's
very hard to achieve but possible enough
that it would deter a person from
wanting from wanting to do it and
somebody even say that this the one of
the biggest purpose of this is to stop
people and prevent them from doing it in
public because if it happens in public
whether it's between man and a man woman
a woman or a man and a woman right if
they do in public then everyone will see
it and they will be taken basically to
account for that and they'll be given a
certain punishment so islamically
speaking there's no differentiation and
it's the same case if a man married or
unmarried commits adultery with a woman
or a woman commits adultery with a man
there's a punishment for all these
things because we don't have the same
ideology we don't have the same basic
you know we want to be free and totally
free even though lots of fallacy that
the West has we have well God gives us
laws and we obey God and that is our you
know basically the divine revelation for
the rules that we have so it's like
literally a completely different society
that you cannot compare using Western
values and Views and and all that stuff
that's why the condemnation of Qatar
makes literally no sense because you're
condemning them based on a criteria that
you made imagine I come to you and I'm
like I have a criteria for a man you
have to be six foot nine you have to be
either African or Asian you have to have
hair down to your ears and you have to
be uh good at soccer and basketball
and then I come to everyone here and I'm
like you guys all suck because you don't
meet the criteria I made that's exactly
what the West does when it comes to
Muslims